the new york jets are going to try to
figure out what's in the best interest
of their team they hold the second
overall pick in the draft
but they've got sam darnold the guy they
gave up three second round picks to get
by moving from six to three
just three years ago here is joe douglas
the gm
of the jets talking about sam darnold
and his future
look we've got a lot of decisions to
make you know i
i i think that sam's going to be a great
quarterback
you know i'm excited to to get a head
coach in here
um go through our process um you know i
had a great conversation with sam
yesterday
um can't i won't go into into the
specifics but
you know i think i think sam has a very
bright future in this league
and so um you know we're going to get a
head coach in here
we're going to we're going to get
together we're going to talk about
uh quite a few decisions and so um
no i'm excited about sam
remember larry the cable guy every time
i see joe douglas i think larry the
cable guy
i i don't you i i hear you yeah he's got
every damn time he is an awesome guy too
but joe's a little more impressive of a
man like has a little more muscle
density larry cable guy is just fat
i've been around him he's just fat
sorry larry he'll understand
i don't even know where larry the cable
guy is anymore i haven't seen anything
or heard anything about him in a long
time but anyway that's just
i don't know it's the goatee it's the
look right sure rip the sleeves off rip
the sleeves off of that uh that hoodie
and you're good to go
um far more importantly the substance of
what joe douglas
had to say sam darnold or the second
overall pick in the draft
somebody asked me yesterday what are
they going to do well we don't know
until they have a coach
right you don't know what the coach is
going to think of sam darnold you know
what the coach is going to think of the
guys coming in
will the coach have a plan for sam
darling i think this is part of what you
interview for you wait to see
what the coaches say their plan will be
sure i have a plan for fixing sam
darnold
i have a plan for getting the most out
of justin fields
i have a plan for trading up to get
trevor lawrence
these are all things that i think you
need to be willing to absorb
as you interview these candidates and
you hope that the candidates
are telling you what they truly believe
not what they think you want to hear
just so they can get the job that's a
dynamic as well
that can rear its ugly head during these
kinds of interviews
no doubt i mean no doubt we saw that to
be an issue a few years ago with the
jaguars job and blake bortles where that
was a huge thing with the the
coaches being you know uh interviewed in
that process
um but yeah this is gonna be interesting
it really is this is one of the the best
story lines i think of the off-season
what the jets do with the position
they're at
you know they're they're in a they're in
a good spot in a lot of ways
yeah you can take a quarterback adjust
them fields if you want if you're blown
away by it
hey you could hope that some other team
really likes them and wants to trade up
and get them there's that avenue
but yeah when you do that yes you're
saying it would keep sam darnold
i do think there's many people within
the jets organization that still believe
in sam darnold
i'm one of those guys mike i understand
it's not clear cut
but i feel i've seen enough when i watch
them and on film to go
i think you can win and be successful
with sam darnold i'm not saying it's
going to be aaron rodgers or patrick or
holmes no
but i would tell the jets and jets fans
to be careful about wanting to trade
them
you know and trading away you know well
and then going to a quarterback you
don't know
you know what they're going to be again
i'd like to remember
remind jets fans this guy was called
sammy the savior when he came to town we
thought it was all done right then
who's to say this can't all happen again
you know so build a team i think you can
win around sam darnold
and maybe they can trade that pick and
add to their team overall
and become a better team you know you
heard me say the other day it's like the
miami dolphins i know tannehill and
miami needed to split ways
exactly but i was gonna say it's ryan
that's the name that the jets fans need
to keep in mind
get rid of sam darnold right ryan tanah
exactly like
how good would it would the dolphins be
going in the super bowl this year right
now if you had ryan tannehill
and maybe could have made the number
five pick
something else i don't know whether you
trade down or drafted somebody right
there maybe you traded down and you got
justin jefferson a little later or
something like that
who knows but that's the point like what
you're saying exactly right
be careful there because you could have
a winning formula let's not just ditch
it for a quarterback quarterback
quarterback quarterback when you have a
one that i think is pretty solid already
well the guy that you throw overboard
could go somewhere else in your division
or in your conference and
help a team take a playoff spot that
maybe you would get
like the dolphins 10 and 6. they're out
titans in
titans have ryan tannehill that is a
very real concern when you start
talking about telling a quarterback to
pack up his stuff
and leave um the trevor lawrence angle
fascinates me though because if urban
meyer takes the jaguar's job
right before and i don't know that he
would want justin fields over trevor
lawrence but before you would take
justin fields over trevor lawrence
you would try to get the jets to trade
up to number one so they could get
trevor lawrence so if you're a jets fan
don't rule out the possibility of
getting trevor lawrence
because if meyer gets the jaguars job
and he wants justin fields
i think they're going to call the jets
at some point and say you can get trevor
lawrence
what are you willing to give us to move
from two to one yeah
that you're right that is a possibility
you know
and you're right we don't know how urban
we don't know if he's gonna be the head
coach in jacksonville we don't know how
he feels about justin field you
real we realize he's gonna have great
information you know
i'm like urban wasn't there with fields
right
he he came the year after he left and
then right but he recruited it but he
knows all of them right he saw him on
tape
all of those type of things and of
course i'm sure he's got the greatest
scouting report ever there from ohio
state so you're you're right mike that
that can be an angle to watch out for
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports